I thought we'd look at another one of
your template applications the one
called storage event function app yep we
call that one scaler for short because
it's an image scaling application it
shows you how to write an event driven
serverless application there are two
parts uh first the function that listens
to any file that's uploaded and resizes
it second there's a small Client app
that shows the files that are present
and you know actually allows for
uploading the most important part of the
app is the cloud function here it's
triggered when a new file is uploaded to
cloud storage bucket the function
contains the image resizing code instead
of doing everything in the uploader we
can keep things decoupled by using
events in this case we run a function
whenever the file uh file added or file
created event is fired thanks for
showing me your app Terry and thank you
everyone for watching use Terry's app as
a template to build your own app that
handles uploaded files